I think right now I'm,
one of the ways they're making our lives
better is they make people think right.
That's one of the things.
Video Games are good at you in order to
win the game.
You can't just sit there,
you have to think,
you have to think and engage and make
decisions.
And I think right now when you,
when you talk now to the people who are
at the forefront of educational reform,
all of them are talking about how do we
use these games.
I see how powerful they are.
They're all picking them up like some
kind of sword and trying to charge in to
figure out how to use this to make
education better.
I think in terms of improving ourselves,
I think that's one of the areas we're
going to see at the forefront,
but I think they're going to be many
other areas as well.
I mean we've already seen the success of
things like the we fit,
which is,
you know,
an exercise platform,
uh,
for the,
for the weekend.
It's been incredibly popular in terms of
people sticking with it and it really
changing their lives.
I'm not so sure,
but the fact that they've already made I
think $2,000,000,000
selling those things speaks to the fact
that this is something people want you,
you know,
you talk to wealthy people who have a
personal trainer and they talk about how
effective it is.
This person comes in and says,
you need to do this and you need to do
that and there's a social pressure in
order for you to kind of do this and not
let the trainer down and trainers know
these kinds of psychological tricks in
order to kind of put you right at the
right level.
You need to be.
Everyone will be able to have that kind
of personal trainer.
I'm not only just for the physical,
physical things and exercise,
but for their education,
for their hobbies,
for their art,
for their spirituality,
for anything in their life that they'd
like to improve.
That is certainly true.
That there are people who,
uh,
play video games in a way that makes
their life out of balance.
Usually these are people who have some
significant gap in their life and
they're,
they're filling it with something.
In a way that is isn't healthy.
Um,
some people say,
you know,
you occasionally hear people make this
accusation that,
well,
you know,
the way there's these problems with
video game addiction,
it's ruining people's lives.
And the problem is these video game
designers try and make the games too
compelling.
They designed the games to be addictive
and if they would just stop doing that,
the problem would go away.
But this is like saying that obesity is
the fault of the bakers.
We're making the cakes too delicious.
And if only you would make the cakes a
little less tasty,
there would be this whole obesity
problem would go away,
right?
That's not where the problem,
the problem lies.
The problem lies with people
understanding how to take these
entertainment experiences and integrate
them in a healthy way,
um,
incident their lives,
uh,
as,
as predominant as these entertainments
are in our lives.
The problem does not.
I mean,
it's definitely a problem for some
people.
It doesn't seem to be an epidemic
problem.
It is definitely a problem for some
people and it's certainly worthy of sort
of study and understanding about how to
best manage it.